nicolas sarkozy qui a par ailleurs jugé
grotesque blessant et mensongers
l'article du canard enchaîné ce matin
selon laquelle il aurait promis une
amnistie déguisée à jacques chirac si il
était élu à onze jours du premier tour
la campagne est entré dans sa dernière
ligne droite
les meetings se multiplient gérard
schivardi marie george buffet et
françois bayrou était hier soir sur le
terrain tandis que marine le pen au nom
de son père s'est rendu sur un marché ce
matin
carnet de campagne est signée bénédicte
doré programme et bravo pour le régime
rayonnante dans la dernière ligne droite
de la campagne
elle en est sûre son père sera encore
une fois au second tour
je pense que jean marie le pen lui
pour aller au second tour je pense que
le seuil d'accès au second rang est à
20% et que nous sommes dans un étiage
qui peut permettre à jean marie le pen
d'être second tour comme en 2002 dans
les derniers sondages le candidat du fn
recueille près de 14% d'intentions de
vote loin des meetings starisé c'est
dans cette petite celle de dijon que
gérard schivardi a égrené son programme
hier soir 200 personnes mais toute la
presse comme pour les grands et
l'occasion de souligner sa différence
avec les autres candidats
c'est le seul programme parmi les douze
candidats qui couteau âgé et à la fraise
alors je vais t'expliquer au studio il a
beau drôle sur d'abord on va
nationaliser les vagues mais faute de
position il avait gagné l'argent sur
notre dos qu'ils auront un mois que je
dis
ambiance survoltée pour la régence du
fait qu' elle s'est offert le zénith
puis loi et devant une salle comble elle
en remet une couche sur le vote utile
la gauche oui mais avec les communistes
si vous vous le peuple de gauche vous
céder à la pression du vote dit utile
c'est toute la gauche qui sera affaiblie
c'est toute la gauche que vous isolez de
ses attaches populaire si vous céder aux
sirènes du renoncement
si vous n'étiez pas là gonchar met la
barre à gauche elle perdra elle perdra
face à nicolas sarkozy à quelques
kilomètres de lille françois bayrou
était dans le bassin minier
rencontre avec les ex ouvrier de
metaleurop une rencontre émouvante dans
une région qui souffre du chômage et
plus tard dans la soirée coup de griffe
au patron voyou avec distribution de
bons et mauvais points
je propose en particulier qu'on mette en
place comme pour les accidents comme
pour l'assurance automobile
un système de bonus malus qui avantagera
les entreprises qui ne licencient pas et
qui font tout pour défendre les emplois
et qui donneront une pénalité qui rendra
le chômage moins agréables
financièrement aux entreprises qui
considèreront qu'il est plus facile de
se débarrasser des salariés